the jurogan experience i remember when
um
during this this podcast and he found
out that i actually knew
moses malone like no motion alone how do
you know moses spawned
ah most of the loan is like a very
before he passed so the
the first guy who ever um
invested in my career's name is anthony
colbert and he um he was the first
people to sign destiny's child
they had he had a music company with mo
it's called mole music
and he had been friends with mo for
years so he would moe would be at his
office all the time
and we was in the same building i worked
for this record label called key players
i was the
record pool i gave all the djs they
records so i would
organize records give them out to djs
when i first came home
so moses would be downstairs
and with colbert and he introduced me to
moses and so after that moses
would always recognize me so then one
day
moses is like yo hey
colbert don't want to go to lunch ain't
got time you're gonna go to lunch i'm
like
yeah going [ __ ] lunch with moses
malone
it's this strip club called treasures
that he
loves going to
in houston called treasures
chief best buffet in town best buffet in
town i'm like
huh this is the best buffet
in town like are we are we going to
strip club we're going to eat this the
best buffet time you understand what i'm
saying to you
i go in it's my first time ever having
food going to a strip club for food i'm
like okay
so eating it and the buffet is a huge
ass buffet like a chef
it's lit up it looks like a cafeteria
with the little lamps
but it's all these naked women in here
you know i'm like okay i said so you
like you like crab with your crab he was
like
man um look here now this is the buffer
i say so we argued about
is it the buffet or is the strip club so
it's another it's a male strip club
called a bear in houston i said so
all the men is here if this buffet
was in bear would you go
more like hell no i wouldn't go i said
so it's not the best buffet in town
it's got titties with this buffet this
is what what is important about this
buffet
because if it was penis with the buffet
you wouldn't [ __ ] go eat the buffet
he's like yeah
pretty much correct and that's how me
and moses got tight arguing about
treasures in the buffet
and known him ever since so when he
passed i was at his funeral
and we used to talk all the time i've
been mad at moses one
goddamn time over a motorcycle seat and
this is when you can't
i learned that you really can't tell
people to do what they they owe money
i'll leave you funny man you funny i say
well why don't you invest in my career
how much you need how much you need need
about five thousand dollars to get you
know press kit and all this other stuff
done
moses totally [ __ ] ignored me after
that right
eight months later randomly talking
me him colbert luke randomly talking
he's telling them about that he replaced
the seat
on his motorcycle just because
in the seat costing five thousand
dollars and i
am pissed like he has no idea why i'm
even mad i'm like
so you uh a [ __ ] motorcycle seat he's
like yeah
i just walked out the slam door and cole
was like you know he mad at you
because he asked you to give him five
thousand further his career
and you you didn't ever say anything so
what are you mad about cause you just
[ __ ] spent five thousand a motorcycle
seat that you didn't have to change
and you could have helped him he was
like what [ __ ] i only can't tell him how
to spend my money
it's like he got a alligator
motorcycle seat with a m on it i like it
[ __ ] nice asc that sounds good but i
want it
i get it you know in retrospect though
are you happy that you didn't get the
money from
him i'm excited i was nice because i
think that it would have probably
changed how
we interacted yeah for sure you know
yeah and you know
it's it's things that as an adult
you know why you don't you understand
why you don't get as a comic you have
you definitely have to understand it as
a comic because you know how we are
i'm not getting something right and we
feel like we've been
rejected or pushed to the side and then
you start
some comics start getting better because
they feel like other people are getting
other opportunities but sometimes it's
not for you
in that particular space it's been it's
been shows that haven't
been for me and i've been cool with it
then there's been shows that i thought
that wasn't
for me that i got on like you have the
benefit of hindsight you have the
benefit of
becoming successful and then looking
back and going oh all those things that
went wrong that's probably good
because you develop more character you
understand the business better
and reaching out for someone to help you
it rarely really helps you
you think it's going to help you but
it's going to [ __ ] your relationship
with that person because you're going to
have to pay them back quickly and you're
probably not going to be able to
yeah and then it's also gonna you're
gonna know
that you had to borrow money from
somebody when you know you just did it
yourself it's like you have a piece like
i'm a self-made man you can look at it
that way
and and be easy better better
and who wants to be around like yo you
thinking right there
you know i made him right oh no
he was like that would be that worse
yeah somebody
popping in yo so you know joe rogan
right i'm the
i'm the one that gave him all the [ __ ]
to start his podcast
never brings me up
[Laughter]
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now to
get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience